thank you so much mr speaker my
grandmother
whom i love daily was lying on a
hospital deathbed
and none of us were allowed to be there
to comfort her in her final
moments i couldn't even carry her coffin
on my shoulders
i also had to endure the agony of
watching alone online
the funeral of my uncle my fun-loving
uncle and
we were not there to comfort my
brother-in-law's father who had somehow
contracted covert in a slough care home
during his final moments all this
because we followed
government guidance having experienced
such painful
personal sacrifices like many others
imagine
our collective disgust when in order to
carry favor with the prime minister's
chief advisor
we see psycho frantic spineless
hypocritical government ministers
lining up to defend the indefensible
saying it's time to move on
with some even having the goal to tell
us that they too go for a long drive
when they need to get their eyesight
tested what an absolute disgrace and
they shall be thoroughly
ashamed of themselves so when is the
prime minister finally going to
apologize
to the nation for not mustering up some
courage and integrity
for doing the honorable thing and
sacking his chief advisor who so
shamelessly
flouted his own government guidance that
he could have regained that lost public
trust and confidence and he could have
demonstrated that it's not one rule for
him and he's that he chums
and another for the rest of us
it is a very emotional prime minister
well that's the best thing i can say mr
speaker is
how deeply i think uh i the government
everybody
uh sympathizes with those who've gone
through
the suffering are described by the
gentleman opposite
and no one can uh who hasn't been
through something like that can imagine
uh what it must feel like to be deprived
of the ability
uh to mourn uh properly to hold the
hands
of a loved one in their last moments in
the way that
uh the honorable gentleman describes and
i know how much sympathy there will be
uh with him uh and i i take his
uh his criticisms and most sincerely
of the government uh and everything uh
that we have done but all i can say we
have tried
uh throughout this pandemic to minimize
human suffering
uh to minimize loss of life and uh for
where we have and
for as i've said before when when he
asks me to apologize
i do i apologize uh for the suffering
that the people of this country have
endured and
all i can say is that nothing and uh i
can say or do
uh can uh take back uh the
the lost lives uh the lost time spent
with loved ones that he describes and
i'm deeply deeply
sorry for that
you